hello my name is Karen Gordon with la
talk radio skill courage i'm here with
filmmaker Gary King how do you write a
Joe Sherman song is on Kickstarter right
now and you know Gary you were one of
our first few guests on film courage
when we still had our training wheels on
not that we have them off really but um
you were one of the first and it's been
about a year since you've come on how
have you grown creatively as a person
what I what did you what do you know now
that you didn't know then in that year's
time I think though the main thing that
I've learned is the power of social
networking has has blown me away more
than that I ever expected a year ago
because I just wrapped a feature film
you lately and I was in the middle of
shooting another one when I appeared on
your show was kind of promoting that but
from your show and also just being on
Twitter a four whole years since then
has just made me realize there's so much
out there that you can tap into just by
being a new computer and and sharing and
work and connecting with people because
a year ago I still with New York lately
was just doing their traditional
marketing after he made the film I I
waited till I was done and then I
started trying to promote it afterwards
and the festivals and getting the word
out there but after doing your show and
also realizing that was a mistake by
starting the promotional way too late
with what's up lovely as I was shooting
i started to share it i started to tell
people about it already here is what i'm
doing still shots of what we're doing
and then did a trailer but started that
right from pre-production right when i
knew i was going to make the film and
started letting people know about it
letting the Twitterverse and facebook
people know about it and I think that is
sort of a lesson that once I started
connecting and following other people
and seeing how they were doing it and it
made me realize I wanted to follow their
films all the way from pre-production to
post and finally see the phone films
like heart of now is that for something
he was very very good at doing that kind
of thing we're sharing the project
letting people know what it's out there
and sharing the process about how he's
getting it to a final product and then
getting it out there so very
inspirational people like that have
helped me learn a lot now what are some
of the hardest parts about social media
because you hear people who say you know
I don't want to be on Facebook they're
they're fake friends it's not real what
do you think alright what I mean I and
there's also an obligation to to keep
going to retweet people that have
tweeted you what are some of the hard
parts about social media I guess the
hard parts there are connections to be
made and it is almost like a friendship
but it's a long distance friendship and
you still do have to keep it up because
you can't be one sided because no one's
ever gonna support someone who's always
talking about themselves even in real
life you don't really like to hang out
with friends that just sit there and
talk about me me me you know so it's
something that it's a fine line and it's
a something as a balance to learning
that you do have to be online for a
while to figure out maybe you kind of
don't tweet as much but you follow
people just to see how it's done and you
can learn from the people that you enjoy
you don't have to copy any one specific
style but you see the people that you
actually pay attention to and what you
enjoy you you know tail your stuff off
that just see how it works for you